all right another month another marvel
streaming series to talk about first of
all spoiler alert because you know when
i talk about episodes of television or
streaming series this is like i get
spoilers so marvel's what if is a series
that's actually a pretty brilliant
series the series of hypothetical
episodes of what if this one thing was
different what if this person zigged
instead of zagg what if peggy carter
became captain america or captain
britain it starts out with the watcher
narrating it looks like he's going to be
the narrator for all these what-if
episodes voiced by jeffrey wright which
completely makes sense why because if
jeffrey wright has a typecast it's
genius brilliant r d tech guy who also
might have a very intricate
understanding of the multiverse
i just kind of assume that about him
though beyond assumption he did show to
have that understanding in source code
so i just think he's a great voice for
the watcher and i love how this was
executed so this is peggy carter becomes
the super soldier instead of steve
rogers because of one thing she was like
no i'm going to stay and the watcher's
even like all right that's the moment
that's the moment that created this fork
that would lead to a very different
outcome and i love that as explained
many times before and many pieces of
entertainment and whatever youtube
videos you might be watching pbs space
time or whatever it's the small changes
that lead to a vastly different outcome
so i appreciate the fact that in this
what if episode the first episode is
this one small decision seemingly small
decision that leads to a vastly
different outcome so the bomb goes off
to like oh we're about to lose a super
soldier program peggy carter's like i'll
get it howard stark flips the switch she
becomes captain carter and they spend
the next 30 minutes doing one thing and
one thing only killing nazis yeah they
don't take scalps for trophies but
nobody's perfect also the animation and
sound design i thought was really smooth
the animation looked great and the sound
is they're actually mcu sound not like
it's a video game adaptation so it
sounds a little different i mean it's
it's marvel studios so they're gonna
have the same sound effects but you
really feel that when the vibranium
shield is smashing into helmets smashing
into soldiers smashing their heads to
the ground in a fight scene or sequence
i like the animation that's just like
one frame boom bam and concrete just
cracks i dig it that's what they didn't
hear i really felt the impact that's
what i'm looking for in something like
this but this episode does answer that
decade-long question could the plot of
captain america the first avenger be
crushed down into 30 minutes
yeah i mean it's not a play-by-play but
they pretty much go through the main
beats of the plot of captain america the
first avenger they have the train scene
the train blows up you think steve
rogers dies he has a big mech by howard
stark which at first i was like what
howard stark made an iron man suit or an
iron monger suit anyway in world war ii
but makes sense because tony stark was
able to build this in a cave with a box
of scraps so i suppose his dad could
build a big mech suit in world war ii
but it was neat to see things play out
differently it was neat to see captain
carter come to the modern age with
actually samuel l jackson voicing nick
fury she basically comes to the portal
the way loki did but it was her and now
she's in the 21st century i like that
jeremy runner was hawkeye in that one
scene samuel l jackson was nick fury in
that one saying the voices for the most
part were the people you knew from the
live-action version say for a couple
chris evans is not steve rogers also as
we saw from the trailer robert downey jr
is not going to be tony stark those guys
are like i got my money i will now enjoy
the beach i don't know that's what i
would do i'd be like you can find me on
a cruise ship somewhere or in space i
don't know we're sending people to space
now why not and i guess in one of the
episodes to come when t'challa is in it
that's actually chadwick boseman so
that'll cut deep down too young this
[ __ ] just messes me up
there are no guarantees in life hug your
loved ones but in the end i'm enjoying
the concept of marvel's what if half an
hour adventures that are hypotheticals
or at least a glimpse into another
reality all the buildups in this half an
hour episode so sometimes it did feel
like this episode was going really fast
like it didn't stop to breathe what was
still really entertaining kind of
mentally takes me back to the original
star wars clone wars series not the
clone wars series but clone wars season
one anyway season two had a more linked
narrative with the episodes but season
one was like these three to five minute
episodes of just all right here's one
scenario moving on to the next for the
next episode and it was pretty sweet and
i loved it it's like that but you know
half an hour long the possibilities of
what they could do are literally endless
they could do a new season of this show
every year and never run out of ideas on
a personal note this whole thing just
kind of wraps into how i see
consciousness in reality i see reality
as a plinko board yes the price is right
game where every possible path of the
plinko chip is actually played out in
different universes every decision is a
peg and every decision you make is the
plinko chip hitting the peg bouncing
either right or left depending on how
you hit it what decisions you make so
your consciousness is continually moving
through the multiverse based on the
decisions you make as is the
consciousness of every other version of
you that to me is just kind of how i see
consciousness and reality where plinko
chips bouncing down the board based on
the decisions we make the decisions
being the peg that bounces the chip here
or there anyhow that's my take that's
how i see it alright so marvel's what if
episode one the episode with captain
carter have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you